me now is kentucky senator rand paul
senator great to see you tonight um i
think that more than
more than past elections this one really
is about common sense
and the left's utter rejection of it do
you agree
yeah and the thing is is there's an
enormous disconnect between those in
washington and those on the ground like
in kentucky we lost 40 people to severe
flooding recently in eastern kentucky
hundreds of homes were lost and i was
just out there not one person said can
you please send more money to ukraine
they said how come we're a rich country
and we're having trouble digging our
ditches repairing our roads and all the
basic functions of government and yet
the politicians in washington want to
send another 13 billion
after they send this 13 billion we'll
send over 50 billion dollars to ukraine
and people in eastern kentucky are
saying how come we can't repair our
bridges how come we can't repair our
roads and so i find nobody in kentucky
coming up and saying please send more of
our money overseas and yet in washington
it's not just democrats you got
democrats and all the republican
leadership lining up saying please send
more of our money to ukraine but i'm not
hearing it at home at all
now you talk about that disconnect
senator and today president biden
unveiled one of his new so-called
accomplishments
made in america is no longer just a
slogan
earlier this year went to lockheed's
factory in alabama
they're making the javelin missile that
we're supplying to ukraine senator how
does the production of javelin missiles
for ukraine
help americans i guess except the
americans at the factory i guess
yeah i've never really been big on
looking at arms programs as jobs
programs i think that our weapons are
uniquely owned by the taxpayer even if
private organizations make these and
when there shouldn't be something it's
like oh well let's give more weapons to
create jobs by you know getting involved
in more wars overseas no we don't really
have the money to do this we're 30
trillion dollars in the hole and it's
inflationary you borrow more money to
buy weapons it also causes inflation and
so really what i hear still around
kentucky and around the u.s is my gas
cost so much we can't go on vacation
this year the groceries cost so much i'm
a senior citizen my check is getting
thinner and thinner i can't afford to do
the things i want to do because of
inflation and they all instinctively
know this is from the massive debts the
massive borrowing and the huge covet
lockdowns and all the mistakes that were
foisted upon us by democrats by biden by
the democrat congress and so i think
there's a huge wave building i really
still think there's a huge wave i do of
discontent and people are going to want
to throw the bums out who have caused
all this inflation
yeah and everything's tightening you see
that with the blake masters race two
points or three points uh the new
emerson pole fetterman in pennsylvania
and you've got your own race in
tennessee senator but you've got a
healthy lead i know you're not taking
anything for granted i think kentucky
excuse me i don't know why i said
tennessee oh my gosh
i don't know about that connecticut
yankees
but my lead in kentucky
i got you yeah i got you we are fighting
hard in kentucky
and things are are are narrowing across
the u.s but we're fighting hard here and
if people want to go to rand paul.com
they can find out more about our race
but we're fighting hard to let people
know that i'm a different kind of
republican i'm a kind of republican that
doesn't fly around the world at taxpayer
expense i'm a kind of republican who
also says you know what i'm going to
give money back to the treasury from my
office i'm not going to spend all the
money they give me i'm going to give
back so my office has actually given
back over 5 million
to the treasury awesome that's awesome
and i'm going to tweet out your new ad
senator which i just saw which is
fantastic i don't know who made that ad
for you but now everybody's going to be
curious so they're going to have to go
to my twitter uh to see it senator
fantastic
to see you haven't seen you in a while
so thank you so much hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else